well before we begin I was I was reading
an email earlier this morning from from
somebody responding to my show yesterday
which was about masculinity and she says
that there's too much macho manly stuff
going on in the culture and it's it's
okay for a man to cry you know to show
his feminine side and cry I like a man
who cries is what you said and that just
got me thinking and I wanted to
stipulate it's just kind of as a public
service announcement at the top and it's
not related to anything else we're gonna
talk about but let me just stipulate
one thing about crying it is is
generally not okay for a man to cry
except for in in the following seven
situations there are seven situations
where a man can cry the first one death
of a loved one
obviously crying's okay there the second
one a major milestone involving your
kids like when your kid is born when
child graduates that sort of thing
the third thing during an intense
spiritual experience crying is okay
there the fourth of course when you're
watching the the final scene of Rudy
when when they're chanting for Rudy and
he finally comes out and he makes them
he makes a tackle and the tackle is
totally irrelevant because the game's
basically over
but it's he's been working for it his
whole life and then everyone's cheering
and his dad is there and they carry him
off the field you can you can weep over
that as a man the the fifth thing if
you're kicked in the shins by a horse I
think is a good is a fine crying
situation the sixth thing if your if
your wife makes you a lasagna
that is just so good that it brings you
to tears that's acceptable seven
go to somebody's house and this has
happened to me before you go to
somebody's house and they say oh we're
having chili and you say oh wow this
makes my day and then they serve you the
bowl of chili but then you discover that
the chili is made with ground turkey and
black beans then it's it's acceptable
actually to throw the the hot bowl of
chili at the person who served it to you
and cry and that's acceptable not only
morally and ethically but also legally I
believe that's the the law stipulates
that I pretty sure in most states anyway
those are the seven times and there are
in there are no other times that's it
those are the only times when you're
allowed to cry as a man but I can I can
expand on that some other time I want to
respond to something else actually as as
I've as I've mentioned before I get
complaints about the religious content
on my show quite a bit people complain
you know that I talk about God too much
and there's too much Jesus stuff
especially after I did the last show I
was talking about doubt and what do you
do about religious doubts and there was
a ton of complaints from people about
why are you talking about God again I
don't want to hear this and it makes
sense for them to complain because it is
true that I will go into people's homes
with a loaded gun and force them under
threat of death to watch my show so it
makes sense for them to complain that
they don't like the content because
they're forced physically to watch it
now
if I if I weren't forcing people
physically to watch it it would make no
sense at all to complain about my
content it would make sense simply to
not watch it and go live your life and
do something else
because there are after all probably
like a hundred thousand different
podcasts and shows that I'm not
interested in that talk about content
that I don't find interesting but I
don't show up to announce hello this
content doesn't interest me I am NOT
interested in this content and I will
watch the entire thing and remain here
and leave comments letting you know how
uninterested I am I don't do that but
some people follow a different strategy
I guess some people are under the
impression that everything that happens
in the universe must cater to their
special interests and if it doesn't then
they'll complain about it you know then
then they'll barge in and complain it's
it's kind of like if it's like when
people come if you watch whatever
platform you're watching the show on and
you look at the comments and there are
people complaining I don't find this
interesting I don't like this this I
don't like that's like if if you're
walking by somebody's house and the
windows were open and you could hear
what sounded like the people inside
playing Scrabble and so you knocked on
the door and when they answered it you
said I don't like Scrabble
and they said okay did anyone ask you if
you liked it you we weren't even invited
to place I don't know what who are you
what's it what are you doing here at my
house I don't like Scrabble no I don't
like it
what happens in the comment section
under all my videos
but when I have a discussion and by the
way I I have decided to change my policy
this is good news I will no longer be
forcing people at gunpoint to watch or
listen I'm gonna stop doing that I've
decided that it's not really in keeping
with my Christian convictions I won't do
that anymore so you are free everyone is
free to not to do what you want you
don't have to be here if you don't want
to be
but when I've discussed before the
complaints about the religious content
on my show most of the time I'm focusing
on atheist and secular people are
criticizing for it unfortunately though
and this really shouldn't be too
surprising it's not only atheists very
often I hear from Christians who are
upset that I'm talking about Christian
stuff for instance got an email from a
guy after that show who ever was - three
days ago and he said and I hear this a
lot this is a this is a very common line
that you hear he said if I wanted to
hear about this I'd go to church
and I didn't ask him but I'm sure if I
okay well when do you go to church well
I went in 1987 that's the last time I
wanted to hear about this stuff
now he says he doesn't want to hear
about God and religion all the time
there's a there's a there's a time and
place for it he said but my own show is
not a time or place he's decided that's
not a time or place
in fact it's if he income comes in
contact with a conversation about
religion then it is immediately not a
time in place it must always happen in
places where he cannot hear it you know
he was saying I need to separate the
religion stuff from everything else and
I shouldn't bring God and religion to
everything and so on and so on and this
again is something that I hear a lot
from Christians
and you know when I hear this it brings
to mind
I had with an atheist a little while ago
and he made a very good point it's it's
it's not it's it was not the first time
I've heard a point like this made by an
atheist but he said you know the reason
I don't believe in God or one of the big
reasons is I don't believe that you
believers actually believe how can I be
convinced about God if the people trying
to convince me aren't convinced
themselves and asked him what he meant
by that and he said and I'm paraphrasing
now but he said if I really believe if I
personally really believed in God if I
really believed a supernatural force was
active in the world and was was and this
force had made me and made the world and
made everything and this force is
watching us now and judging and when I
die I'll either go to eternal paradise
or eternal suffering based on how I live
here and if I really believe that like
angels and demons are around me and and
are acting in the world though invisibly
and if I believe that all of that stuff
exists angels Devils hell heaven God all
of that well then I would be obsessed
with that fact I'd be obsessed with it
be the only thing I ever thought about
or talked about
I would live completely differently I
mean I I would live and act and speak
and behave as if there were a
supernatural force watching over me but
that's not how Christians in this
country act that's not how they talk
that's not how they carry on not even
close
they mostly just carry on the same as
everyone else
which makes it clear that they don't
really believe what they say they
believe
because if they did it would be such a
significant fact
I thought that was a great point and by
the way I've heard a similar point made
by pro-abortion people in relation to
pro-lifers I bet there's every
pro-abortion people say if you really
believed that babies are being killed
why aren't you acting like two why
aren't you doing anything about it
I mean and they'll say you know if there
was a building down the street where
they were killing two-year-olds I mean I
would
I would really act upon that in a way I
mean I wouldn't just sit around and I
think that you know it's hard for us to
hear this but these are very good points
and we need to face them
because they're right
and this is the consequence of being
secularized Christians living in a
secularized country this is the
consequence of insisting that God be
separated from normal life and normal
discussions this is the consequence of
treating our religion as something that
belongs only in church the consequence
is that nobody believes us and we don't
really believe ourselves nobody takes us
seriously neither and they shouldn't
because we don't take ourselves
seriously we make these extraordinary
claims about the nature of life and
about what we believe but then that
claim is not reflected in anything else
we do
so if you're a Christian saying I don't
like all the Jesus dog it makes me
uncomfortable let's talk about something
else
well the atheists around you they may
agree with you and they may be happy
that you're joining them in their
efforts to shut down religious
conversations but they're also laughing
at you
in their heads because you're a
ridiculous figure you're a fraud you are
you're laughable
and they're right to see you that way
and to treat you like that
because what what are you doing takin
their side they they believe in a world
where there's no God and it took makes
sense for them to be saying this stuff
but you what are you doing I thought you
believed in this force who is I mean
imagine imagine that God
imagine that you you this is what we
talked about the video two days ago but
imagine that you did walk outside your
house and you could see you could
literally physically see God in the sky
like he was encompassing I don't mean
that he's living this guy I mean you've
seen this this it's this infinitely
immense being just hovering over
everything right and looking right at
you
directly at you
would you not be obsessed with that fact
would you be able to go and talk about
something else
and if somebody said to you hey you know
hey about that about God up there would
you say no let's not talk about that
no you wouldn't
but as Christians we believe that though
we can't see him that is actually
literally what's happening he is there
over and above and in and through
everything a personal being looking
directly at us
um
so wouldn't we do this thing which yeah
you know I want to talk about that
well then we we come off as frauds and
we have no chance of reaching anyone we
don't have it yet we have no chance of
reaching atheists or anything like that
because they know that it makes no sense
for someone who believes in God to not
want to talk about it and if you believe
in God and you really believe it then it
must be the most relevant thing in your
life and every conversation everything
is tied to this fact
but we have
participated as Christians in the
secularization of culture we as
Christians have participated in this
process of separating God from life we
we've not only participated it but we've
been the driving force of it
we have been facilitators of it we've
been encouraging it we have made two
different camps two divisions and so
there's the God camp and then there's
the everything else camp and the God
camp is very small it doesn't get a lot
of room to operate and the everything
else camp encompasses most of the rest
of the landscape and and so that we as
Christians can live in this camp over
here and we could acknowledge that that
that camp exists but it's you that
acknowledgement has no bearing on our
lie on our lives or on our conversations
and we just continue about our life as
if that camp doesn't exist as if it
really is completely separate if the two
things are completely separate
we live a theist lives
and if we acknowledge God's existence at
all it's maybe for a few minutes on
Christmas and then maybe if something
happens to us that we really need we
need his help then we might say Oh God
can you come here for a minute I need a
promotion at work yeah just come here
and okay thanks Marshall now go back to
that go back over there go go go go
the point is we've created an
environment that's Christians I think
we've created an environment where faith
in the gospel cannot be preached because
effectively because faith and the gospel
must exist in the culture intertwined
with everything that's what faith
demands considering the claims that it
makes about life it makes claims that if
we believe those claims should alter
everything we do think and say
by its nature faith has to be
all-encompassing it really is an
all-or-nothing proposition people tell
me all the time it's not all or nothing
it's not black or white
it is that's exactly what it is that's
exactly what God is all or nothing he is
either all or he is nothing he cannot be
anything in between
I think we look for that in-between
things
you
want to live and operate
as if there is no God yet still say that
we believe him
this is not this is pretty unprecedented
I think in history for most of the
existence of Christianity for most of
Christendom x' history this this didn't
exist you didn't have this dichotomy of
well there's God over here and then
there's life right there was none of
that
there was just God and faith was was a
part of everything it was just it was he
was ingrained in everything it was your
life and that made sense so if you go
back to supposedly the Dark Ages which
were times much more spiritually
enlightened than the times we live in
now by the way so if those were the Dark
Ages then I don't know what this is now
but if you go back to the dark' the
Middle Ages the Dark Age what you're
gonna find is that people that they drew
no distinction whatsoever between faith
and religion and life it was all
everything was all together there was no
distinction that couldn't even conceive
of a distinction
there was no out you really didn't have
the option to be a secular Christian you
couldn't be that that it that was not an
option for life
and so in although back in those days
back in older times it would have been
it would have been harder to live
physically it would have been more
physically challenging and demanding
certainly I think spiritually it was
easier it was easier to be a Christian
then because things just kind of made
sense you lived in a society
um
really just acted and operated like they
really believe this stuff
and that's what society was there was no
dividing line
in there there there shouldn't be I
don't know how we as Christians can
argue that yeah we should keep God out
of this but how can you I understand why
atheists it how could you possibly say
that as a Christian keep God out of it
you must know that you can't so possible
and nothing good can ever come out of
keeping God out of anything out of
anything
this is again if we if we lived 500
years ago we wouldn't be having it
wouldn't be necessary for me to make
this point everyone would have look at
me like yeah of course what are you
talking about
and now I say it and Christian
Christians are disagreeing well yeah but
you know you can't involve God in this
so ridiculous so weak so flimsy so
ridiculous so so stupid I mean if you
want to be an atheist just be an atheist
don't try to turn Christianity into
atheism
by the way this is why I'm so opposed to
anything that that hints of
secularization in the church because
we've got the entire culture is
secularized right we live in a secular
culture we live in a culture where as I
said it is it is it is feet not just
feasible but
very easy to live as a secular Christian
and to separate your faith from
everything else you do in your life and
to not even really think about it it's
it's possible to live that way that is
an option that never used to be an
option for living now it is and very and
most people that's the option they
select well maybe which makes it harder
for Christians who want to really live
like Christians it makes it harder for
them because there's there's there's
more of an effort and just an effort it
requires effort like every second of the
day and you're gonna get pushback not
just from atheists but from other
Christians who mock you and laugh at you
for actually taking the religion
seriously that they supposedly share
with you but at least in a church
at least you should be able to go to a
physical church
and there's a it's a safe haven and it's
it's it's an oasis different from all
the rest of this
you got secularization everywhere you
should at least be able to go to a
church and escaped secularization and
find a place that is grounded in the
reality of God but that's not what
happens in most churches you should be
able to walk into a church
and everything about it should be
completely different from what you see
in the world today it should be shocking
at this at this point it should be
shocking to walk into a church every
time you walk in you should be taken
aback like whoa this is different
everything from the architecture to the
music to the dress to the certainly to
the message being preached the attitude
the demeanor of the congregants all of
it should appear to be like from a
different universe because it is from a
different universe it is from a universe
where God exists and rules over all as
opposed to the universe that our secular
culture tries to live in where God does
not exist in is irrelevant but that's
not how it goes instead most churches
look and sound and in every way resemble
the rest of the culture most churches
appear to be extensions of secular
culture products of it rather than
windows into something eternal and
sacred and and supernatural and the
effect is that you can go to most
churches in America or many anyway you
can go and you can sit in the church and
you can attend the service you can
listen to the music you can listen to
the sermon or the homily and you can
still all the while continue on
forgetting about God
the reality of God even in most churches
in America is not really thrust upon you
you're not really forced to face it he
might be mentioned but the fact that
again you live in this in a reality
where God is present and looking at you
all the time
that you're not really in most churches
forced to confront that reality and the
way the church itself operates it does
not appear to be grounded in that
reality
just with the just how casual everything
is there's just no sense of reverence no
sense of anything sacred happening
none of that
instead it's like people
people just stroll in casually
I mean if you really believe especially
at church where church is like the
special place
or God I mean God is present everywhere
but at a church you know two or three
are gathered as scripture says God is
with us and he is you're really there
you're really focusing on God more than
you more than what happens in secular
culture and so he's really there in this
special sense I think there should be
this just total reverence and
I mean imagine that you were in church
and Jesus himself appeared there
physically right in front of you
how would you react
may wouldn't you fall to the floor in
just in in total reverence to this
divine being
or would you just continue along which
most people do in church they just sit
back and they're chatting and they're
just you know super casual the music is
nice and secular and kind of casual a
lot of churches now they got the little
they got the donuts and the coffee they
got a coffee shop people are sitting
there sipping their coffee is that what
you'd be doing if Jesus appear right in
front of you would just be like oh hey
Jesus hey how's it going
in a secular culture everything is
designed with the intent I think of
keeping our minds focused on now on
material things and it seems now that
even churches are designed with that in
mind
and it's a big problem
it isn't hard to see how Christianity in
the early days was able to spread so
rapidly through pagan cultures while it
seems to be fading and dying in our
supposedly sophisticated modern secular
culture because people back in those
times even in pagan beep not just not
just in Christian society but even pagan
people lived in a world where the
spiritual and the supernatural and the
mystic were all front and center in
their daily lives everyone had an idea
of life as as this thing that was
inexorably tied to something else
something infinite something beyond it
and so it was just a matter of for
Christians was a matter of coming into
these societies where this works where
spirituality and and super and
supernatural forces all of that was
already taken for granted as being as
being real and being part of life and so
you just come in and correct their
spiritual ideas and kind of redirect
them in the right direction but America
today is a spiritual vacuum there's
nothing to build upon
there's no spirituality there's there's
all we're just we live in a material
world and we are material girls as
Madonna rightly observed so I think
to bring it all back together that means
that we as Christians
I think have to make a considered effort
to keep God and keep our faith at the
forefront of our minds and of our
conversations and of everything we do
like even though it's hard because to
live that way is so alien and foreign to
most people in our culture including
most Christians so if you do you're
going to be mocked by them and they're
gonna look at you like you're a a weirdo
and you're gonna be looked even in most
churches that's how they're gonna treat
you but
I think when we do that we're not only
helping ourselves and our own souls and
our own spirituality but we're helping
everyone else because
we at least are living as if and
speaking and acting as if we really
believe
and so at least there's a us I mean
we're perfect doesn't mean we're Saints
it just means we believe this and so
we're just we're operating as if we
really believe it
and then at least there's a chance
there's there's there's there's a chance
of a little bit of that light poking
through the darkness and of getting
through to people
at least there's a chance
just like them and if we if we toss God
off to the corner of existence and we
don't talk about them and we don't bring
them up there's no chance
all the lost sheep out there there's no
chance of us getting to them
because there's no light right
all right we'll leave it there I hope
you guys have a great weekend Godspeed